[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELISE ROY: You see this?
This is my old hearing aid.
And this?
This is one that I wear today.
What's different?
This one's flesh-colored
and this one's red.
It may seem like a small design
tweak, but it changed my life.
It made me feel as
if I belong again.
You see, right before fifth
grade, my mom sat me down
and she said, you need to tell
Michelle about your hearing
loss.
Michelle was my best
friend, but I hadn't
seen her all summer long.
And two weeks before, I was told
that I was losing my hearing
and it was going to just get
worse and worse and worse.
But I was 10 years old.
I didn't know how to deal
with heavy stuff like this.
And so when I called her
up before school started,
we talked about our summers,
we talked about sports,
we talked about everything
but my hearing loss.
On the second day of school,
she was standing behind me
in line and she tapped
me on the shoulder,
pointed to my hearing aid
and said, what's that?
It was an innocent question, but
I didn't know how to respond,
and so I said,
it's a hearing aid,
as if she was
stupid not to know.
And then there was just silence.
And this silence followed us for
the rest of our relationship.
She never asked me again
about my hearing loss,
and I spent that year watching
her slowly drift away.
I felt different, as
if I didn't belong,
and she being just 10
years old didn't know how
to deal with this difference.
Many kids avoid difference
because they're just not
sure what to do with it.
And so I found out
quickly that I didn't
want to be seen as different.
And again, this
long struggle to try
to prove that, although
I had a hearing loss, it
didn't change me.
I was still normal.
And I did this by overachieving.
Going-- when I went to
college, playing just one sport
wasn't enough.
I had to play two.
I had to go to an Ivy League.
I became one of the first
few deaf lawyers in the US.
I did some work at
the United Nations,
and then I became a designer.
But somewhere along the
way, I realized something.
I am the new normal.
You know that TV show
"Orange is the New Black"?
Well, I am the new normal.
Difference is the new normal.
Difference, even if it
seems like limitation,
is what makes us thrive,
what makes us valuable.
Now, I would like
to think about this.
This body encompasses all of us.
If we all live long enough,
we will all get disability
at some point in our lives.
And who here has broken
their legs or their arms?
Really, that's it?
Come on.
That's an example of a
temporary disability.
But what comes next is key.
We also all experience something
called momentary disabilities.
Now, I'd like to
call up a volunteer
to come up and help me
demonstrate what they are.
[APPLAUSE]
What I'd like you
to do is to pick up
that box and those
books, and then
come over while carrying the
box, take sip of the water.
You're going to have
to open it, though.
You have to open it.
That was pretty impressive.
Most pe--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
ELISE ROY: Was it easy?
Hard?
AUDIENCE: Totally.
Kind of fun.
ELISE ROY: Yes.
So thank you very
much for your help.
As we go about our lives,
we encounter situations
where we will be
momentarily disabled,
whether we're carrying box
and trying to open up a door.
And so disability really
encompasses all of us.
There are just some of
us that experience it
a lot more than others.
Now, as a lawyer, I fought
for equality and race, gender,
disability, and you
would think that I
would have been outfitted with
the skills necessary to feel
accepted and valued by society.
But to my surprise, I
found the strongest tools
when I transitioned
from law to design.
Design has this powerful
ability to shift perceptions,
but it's up to you to use it.
Up to you.
So finally, it happened.
After law school, I went
back to the audiologist
to get a new hearing
aid, and I was
thrilled because
they weren't just
these awful flesh-colored
things anymore,
but they invented red ones
and blue ones and green ones.
So I opted for the
bright red one,
and then something
magical happened--
my hearing aid became cool.
People started saying things
like, [GASP] love the red!
This little thing created
this huge shift in my life.
It allowed me to
celebrate my difference
and it allowed others to
join in on celebrating
this difference with me.
This is because it
opened up the door
to conversing about
difference without being
focused on limitations.
MICHAEL BRENNER: OK.
Thank you, Elise.
That was a beautiful talk, and
it was a very good introduction
to our story, which we
call Project Euphonia.
So we're going to
start the story
by telling you a story about
one of our colleagues at Google.
So this is Dimitri Kanevsky,
and Dimitri, it turns out,
is a mathematician.
He's worked at some of the great
institutions for mathematics
in the world.
But for the last
two decades, he's
really been thinking
primarily about designing
for accessibility--
that is, trying
to invent technology that was
helpful in some way or other.
So Dimitri himself has a
disability-- he's deaf--
and he also has a very
strong Russian accent.
So the first time that
at least I met Dimitri,
I found it very
hard to understand
what he was talking about.
But, you know, hanging
out with Dimitri,
eventually you get the idea.
So it turns out
that our computers
have the same problem--
that is, when Dimitri
speaks to his phone
as I might speak to
my phone, his phone
doesn't understand
him very well.
And this is a clip in which
he explains that himself.
So what you see from this
is that the phone that
was being showed was a phone
that was running the Google
Cloud Speech Recognition Model.
And what I would claim
is that if you only
looked at the phone,
that you would not
be able to really understand
the thread of what Dimitri
was trying to communicate.
And so we asked ourselves the
question, why is that the case?
Why is it that the phone was
not able to understand Dimitri
but, for example, it is
able to understand me?
And in order to
explain this, I need
to tell you a little bit about
how speech recognition works
and why it is that speech
recognition has gotten so much
better over the past
number of years.
So when we speak, what we're
doing is creating a wave form.
So a wave form is
just a sound wave
and it looks rather
unintelligible.
The job that we're
asking a computer to do
is to take the
picture on the left
and to somehow turn it into
the words that are being said.
So as you all know, humans
have gotten very good
at interpreting
pictures, and so the way
that speech recognizes work
is we first take the wave form
and turn it into a picture.
The picture is
called a spectrogram
and it's just a
picture of colors,
but it's still unintelligible
as to what was being said.
And then what we do
is take the picture
and stick it into a
neural network, which
is a big computer program that
has lots of parameters in it.
And the idea is to make the
computer program so that it
outputs what was being said.
Now of course, just
like us, if you
don't train the
computer program,
it has no idea what
was being said.
And so what we do is we take all
of the numbers in this computer
program-- there are millions of
numbers that you have to tune--
and we give it one sentence
at a time, somebody saying
something.
And the computer
predicts it's saying this
and then it gets it wrong,
and we bang the computer
over the head, twiddle the
parameters around a little bit
until eventually by giving it
lots and lots of sentences,
it gets better at
speech recognition.
And we have phones
that work for people
whom the computer has heard.
Now in order to
do that, it takes
huge numbers of sentences.
So tens of millions,
say, of sentences
need to be given to
the computer for it
to develop a general
type of understanding.
But the problem is that
for people like Dimitri,
or indeed anyone who
speaks in a way that
is different than
the pool of examples
that the computer was given,
the phone can't understand them
just because it's never
heard the example before.
And so the question that we
asked, and this was a question
that we started asking in
collaboration with an ALS
foundation that we've
been working with--
ALS TDI, who gave
me this T-shirt--
so we asked whether or not
it's possible to basically fix
the speech recognizers
to work for people
who are hard to understood.
And Dimitri is amazing and
he decided to take this on.
So remember what I said--
it takes tens of millions
of sentences to train
a speech recognizer.
It's completely crazy to ask
someone to sit and record
tens of millions of sentences.
But Dimitri has a
great spirit, and so he
sat in front of his
computer and he just
started recording sentences.
And so, for example,
here is a sentence--
what is the temperature today?
And so the computer
would say "What
is the temperature today?"
And Dimitri would read "What
And he sat there for days
recording these sentences,
until he had reported
upwards of 15,000 sentences,
and we then decided to
train the speech recognizer
to see if it was able
to understand him.
And I should tell
you that none of us
knew whether or not it was even
conceivable that this could
work because, as I said, it took
many more sentences to train
the thing in the first
place for many people
who speak in a way that is more
typical for speech recognizers.
So here's Dimitri at the end.
He was still happy
after doing this.
And then here is the--
I'm now going to show you a
quick clip of what happened.
And so what you see is that
the device on the right
was able to understand Dimitri,
whereas the device on the left,
which is the Google
Cloud device, was not.
And this really
gave us confidence
that it was possible to
make progress on this task.
And so we started working in
earnest with our collaborators
ALS TDI and which we recruited.
They recruited a
large number of people
with ALS to start recording
sentences to see if this works.
Now, of course, getting someone
to record 15,000 sentences
is completely crazy.
That's never going
to work at scale.
And so instead we were
investigating technically
whether or not it's possible
to make progress with smaller
numbers of sentences.
And what I can report to you
is that we're making progress.
We're not there yet.
We do not feel that we've
solved this problem in any way.
But we're working
hard, and there
are groups of engineers at
Google who are working hard.
And this is just
a little example.
So the last column is
the ground truth phrases,
the rightmost column is
what Google Cloud recognizes
on this particular person
who happens to have ALS,
and the middle column is what
our recognizer is right now
doing, and we're hard at
work trying to figure out
if it is possible to
make this work for people
without requiring so
much training data.
So this is Dimitri
as of this week.
So Dimitri now carries
around with him
about five different phones
in his pocket, each of which
has a different speech
recognizer on it,
and he's testing and trying
to figure out the best way.
And it is our hope
that if we can
get this to work with Dimitri's
help and with all of your help,
and hopefully
people will record,
make recordings for us-- the
reason for this call for data
that Sundar made is that we
need more data from people, just
recordings to be able
to make this work.
Hopefully we will get there.
That is our goal.
And so this sort of
is the general goal
of Euphonia's
mission, which is what
we would like to do is
to improve communication
technology by including as many
people as possible, whatever
features that the
people have and whatever
means to communicate.
Of course, speaking is an
important way of communicating,
but it is not the only
way that we communicate.
We communicate with each
other by looking, by feeling,
by doing so many
different things.
And there are people who don't
have the ability to speak,
and so now I'm going
to turn it over
to Irene, who will start to
talk about other speaking
modalities.
IRENE ALVARADO: All right.
Thanks, Michael.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, so so far
we've talked about Dimitri
and about speech, but what about
other forms of communication?
What about folks who can't
communicate verbally?
We want to show you
how we're approaching
the research for those
types of cases as well.
So for that, I'd
like to introduce
our second protagonist for the
day, the amazing Steve Saling.
He's an incredible person.
He had a brilliant career
as a landscape architect
and when he learned
that he has ALS,
he set about to rethink how
people with his condition
get care.
He also started
thinking about how
he could leverage technology
to create more independence
for himself, so
that he didn't have
to rely as much on other
people to take care of him.
And one thing he
helped do is he helped
create a smart
home-like system that
lets him request an elevator
and close the blinds,
turn on the music, all
by using his computer.
It's really amazing.
So Steve happened to be one of
the perfect persons to partner
with for this research because
he is a technologist himself.
And speaking of
computers, we want
to show you how many folks who
have ALS communicate today.
They use something called
an eye gaze pointer
to type out letters one by one.
So these are two
different systems
that they can use either
a keyboard or something
on the right called Dasher.
And it works-- it does the job--
but if you can imagine,
it's just a little bit slow.
And what he's missing is a layer
of communication that all of us
are familiar with--
interruptions,
mannerisms, jokes, laughs.
Synchronous communication
that comes by quickly.
That's something that's really
hard for Steve and people
with his condition to do.
So something we
wanted to try with him
was to see if he could train his
own personal machine learning
models to classify
different face expressions,
and the thought was,
is this even useful
for him to be able to trigger
things more quickly so that he
might be able to open
his mouth and trigger
something on the computer
or raise his eyebrows
and trigger something else?
It was a question.
It's a research question.
And we didn't know the answer.
So with Steve's feedback, his
ideas, and a lot of testing,
we developed a
machine learning tool
that anybody actually can
use to train classification
models in the browser.
And by classification,
I mean a model
that tries to predict what
category a certain type
of input belongs to.
Let me show you an example
so you see how it works.
This is my colleague Barron and
he's training two classes, one
to detect his face and one to
detect this really cute cat
pillow that he has.
So he's giving the
computer a bunch of data.
He's training it,
waiting for it to finish,
and then he's testing
the model on the right.
And then he publishes the model.
All of this is happening in
the browser in real time,
and the images--
the processing is
happening in his computer,
so the images aren't
being sent to a server.
It's all happening in his
computer in the browser.
So we're calling this
Teachable Machine.
It's a tool for anybody
to train machine learning
models in the browser without
having to know how to code.
And it's actually built
on top of TensorFlow.js,
so all of the underlying
technology is free
and it's open source
for you to use.
So, OK, how is Steve using this?
Well, as I mentioned, he's
training face classification
models for cases where he
might want a faster response
time than what he can achieve
with his eye gaze pointer,
and Teachable Machine
is the prototyping tool
that's allowing him
to do this and explore
what types of use cases are
actually helpful for him.
So why is this useful?
Well, Teachable Machine is
situational in two ways, right?
ALS actually changes over time,
so people with the condition,
they deteriorate over time.
So Steve might be able
to do an expression today
that he can't do in a year.
He has to be able to retrain
those models on his own,
perhaps week by week, month
by month, as he needs it.
And the second thing
is that you might
imagine that he might want
to use different models
for different use cases.
One thing that he
actually tried was
training a model that
would trigger an air horn,
like a sound of an air horn
when he opens his mouth,
and to trigger a boo when
he raises his eyebrows.
And he used it one night
to watch a basketball game
with one of his favorite teams
to react quickly to the game
as it progressed.
Unfortunately that night,
his team didn't win,
but it was actually
really fun to set up.
So we've got a long way
to go with this research.
This is really
only the beginning,
and we hope to expand
the tool to support
many more modes of input.
The tool itself will be
available later this year
for anyone to train their
classification models,
but as I said before,
all of the technology
is already available
on TensorFlow.js.
We're committed to working with
people like Steve and Dimitri
to make their
communication tools better,
and the idea really is to start
with the hardest problems that
might unlock innovations
for everyone.
But it's our sincere hope
that this kind of research
might help people with other
types of speech impairments--
people with cerebral
palsy or Parkinson's
or multiple sclerosis.
And maybe, perhaps
one day, it could
be helpful to even more people--
people who freely communicate
today, maybe like folks who have
an accent in a second language.
And in fact, we started
calling this approach
to building "Start with
One, Invent for Many."
We think anybody
can work this way,
and you can apply to many
more types of problems.
The idea is actually
quite simple--
so start by working
together with one person
to solve one problem, and that
way you can be sure that what
you make for them will
be impactful to them
and the people and their lives.
And sometimes-- it
doesn't always happen,
but sometimes-- what
you make together
can go on to be useful
to many more people.
Start with One, Invent for Many.
If you'd like to hear more
about this project and Start
with One, if you'd like to
hear more about Dimitri, Steve,
and actually play
Teachable Machine,
we have all of these projects
in the Experiment Sandbox
tent, which is actually
really close to the stage.
And finally, lastly,
we'd like to invite you
to help this research effort.
As Michael was saying,
we don't expect
people to train 15,000
phrases in order
to get a model like
this, so we actually
need volunteers to share
their voice samples with us
so that we may one day
generalize these models.
So if you or anyone you know
has hard-to-understand speech,
we'd like to invite
you to go to this link
and submit some samples,
and hopefully one day we
can make these models more
widely accessible to everyone.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]